hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
guess what i'm looking for a new
videographer baby so if you are a
videographer if you're a videographer
you know how to edit you know to shoot
uh videos then i'm interested to hear
from you so i'm going to talk a little
bit about the role i'm also going to
leave in the description i'm going to
leave a link where you can apply and you
can fill out the details and hopefully
i'll get to know you real soon so as a
company i have been documenting for the
last six years i've been documenting not
just my property investment journey but
also
hundreds of my students property
investment journeys and um it's been a
blast it really is i've got a youtube
channel i post regularly instagram
twitter linkedin tick tock so
as a company we are recruiting a new
videographer
amelia
has not left the company yes she's
become financially free um and she was a
videographer but she's still in the
company but she is a talent manager and
um we're just expanding and some of the
guys that i was working with before some
of the freelancers have moved on they've
become entrepreneurs and that's fine a
lot of people that come and work for me
as a videographer they'll work for me
for a year or so and then they'll go off
set up their own company and there's no
issues with that i champion that i love
nothing more than seeing people win so
i'm looking for someone that i can spend
one year with
the whole of 2022
maybe an entrepreneur
but the important thing is someone
that's got skills someone that knows how
to edit videos shoot videos a confident
person someone understands marketing as
well
you can distribute content and i'm
wanting to invest in that person i'm
wanting to work with them to help them
become a better marketer to help them
become a better entrepreneur a better
videographer
and um ultimately a better richer
stronger more courageous person so what
does it look like well
this is a 12 month contract
12 months
there'll be a one month break clause in
place
and over those 12 months i'm looking for
somebody that can just come out on the
road with me travel with me come to the
training programs the events come out
see some of my houses my students houses
it is a tough year working with me is
not um it's not easy because i am a
little bit of a workaholic and i expect
people that are around me to be the same
i'm constantly working i'm constantly
out i'm constantly speaking traveling on
the road so i'm looking for somebody
that can keep up with me
fast-paced
someone that's got experience
as a videographer someone who has got
experience editing videos a quick paced
person a faster learner it's a 12-month
contract i see it like a placement
you're going to learn a lot you're going
to grow a lot um it is a paid position
so it's 25 000 pounds and 25 000 pounds
is not a lot of money you know it's not
a crazy amount of money but i think the
thing is the person that you will become
i have people all the time saying to me
samuel i'll be your videographer for
free and i'm like i don't want you to
work for me for free i want to pay
somebody because i want to have high
expectations of them so that's why it's
12 months
25 000 pounds but also you know you're
going to grow as a person a lot uh lots
of holiday time as well eight weeks
holiday over the year eight weeks
holiday but when you're working you're
working hard so i'm looking for somebody
who can drive somebody who can maybe
move
to uh buckinghamshire just outside
london uh somebody that's ready to go
fall in and immerse yourself and have
the best 2022 ever so if you want to
apply for the role
fill out the details below in the form
and if i mean i probably will get
hundreds and hundreds of applications so
if you don't hear back then i'm sure you
will but if you don't hear back then um
i apologize but anyone that looks good
we'll
reply back to and go through the
interview process and i'm looking for
one new person to work with me as a
videographer 12 month contract
throughout 2022 if it's you
feel the details
below i look forward to getting to know
you man